do you wake up on Monday morning and are
you in a this is awesome like this is
good not like it's okay or like I can
deal with it change a lot of times
people think you have to hit rock bottom
people will change when they hit
quote-unquote rock bottom yeah I mean I
think you have to change if you're not
happy and that comes fancy amazing
situations like you running a team
trying to win an NBA championship but it
also means something for Carl who's
driving to work right now listening to
this podcast and just hates his [__]
job and it's kind of like you know you
hate your job so why not make a change
and try something out if that second
thing is worse then do it again Vayner
Nation what is good another live podcast
not clips from a talk or a video but an
actual podcast that I know you love
those so much and I think you're gonna
really love this one uh my guest today
is someone I adore someone who's
accomplished professionally the things
that I'm up to uh and hopefully would
like to achieve uh Ryan Smith is a
tremendous entrepreneur who built a very
large business and then uh created an
opportunity for himself to now be the
owner of the Utah Jazz I'm especially
really excited to have them on because
we're recording this just a mere 10 or
so days before All-Star Weekend in Utah
we'll try to get this out right away I'm
actually putting out a blog post that
I'll be there uh and actually doing a
public event a little bit of instead of
a kissing booth a q a booth at the Fan
Experience we'll talk about that but
um there's a lot we can touch on but uh
Ryan I think to me represents a new
breed of ownership across the leagues
where you know youthful energy grew up
in in the internet age
um and and just I had a great trip out
to Utah a couple months ago just
incredible what's going on in Salt Lake
we can talk about that but I'll open it
up for him to say hello and and set the
tone a little bit to all of you of what
he wants to say Ryan thanks for being on
the show gee what's up hey anytime man
I'm excited for for everything that's
coming uh if you are anywhere near or
want to be around Salt Lake
um we've got some big stuff planned um
for jam session and everything uh Gary
and I are doing event we've got q a
we've got 60 000 people 60 000 tickets
for for what I grew up going to for
All-Star I mean 30 years ago we had
All-Star in Utah and I obviously I
didn't have enough money to go to games
or wasn't part of that but they had this
jam session what was basically like a
basketball convention yep and it was it
was super cool and like I remember as a
kid going through there and like when
when the league said they were coming
back and we had to just take it over
um one of the things that was a must was
we've got to bring back this jam session
and um it's cool you're a part of it man
I love it tell everybody what GM session
is yeah it's basically we take we take
we've got the convention center which is
adjacent from the arena
and there's you know and I've been to a
lot of games a lot of All-Star games and
one of one of the challenges I have is
like I go to I go to games I go to the
all-star game I want a hoop I like want
to pick up a ball you get the vibe it's
everything basketball and
um that's always been hard to do and so
we brought in I think 14 full court
basketball courts with Legends and
um games then on top of that there's all
sorts of carnival games it's basically a
basketball convention and Utah's a
basketball state it really is a question
this is what we do
um and so we want to have like the
basketball convention
um in about 175 000 square feet of of
convention space where people can
activate Brands
um you know
um individuals like yourself uh who can
come in there and and kind of bring the
culture of basketball hoops of the NBA
all together with a young fan base um
one of the unique things about the jazz
is we have 60 000 kids that participate
in our youth leagues called Junior Jazz
60 000 kids that are part of this junior
Jazz program that every Saturday they
they all hoop with the people around
them and um you know I played that as a
kid
uh my kids play that now and so this is
a chance for all of them to come as well
um and it's really a community event
which I think adds a whole new component
to All Star I understand why people
don't do it every time there's an
All-Star because it takes a lot of work
to curate but
um
it's gonna be it's gonna be a really
cool event and that's only one of the
things we're doing uh we just we just
did um we took we took the west side of
the arena and we did a partnership with
Cactus Jack where Travis is going to
come in and do a Rail Jam which is a
massive snowboard event they're going to
produce concerts every night and then
pop-up shops all the way around with
Cactus Jack
um you know collabs or whatever they're
doing uh and so we're really activating
the entire the entire city and hopefully
it'll it'll go as we've got we got
planned what you know a lot of people
are probably curious about this question
what was
the most surprising thing for you
in reality of owning a sports team
versus
the ideology or thinking you had coming
into it
yeah that's a good where would you use I
ology because I think it's like just
like yourself like your dreams the Jets
the Jets the Jets like you think you
know what that's going to be like
um in a similar way like I grew up
playing Junior Jazz and I remember
talking with Adam
um you know I was looking at another
team because that's what's available you
don't you just like the NFL like even if
you want to own a team or you're in a
position fortunately that you might be
able to play in that space
timing is very very hard like the Utah
Jazz have been in one family the Millers
who had been done an incredible job for
35 years pretty much moved the team here
or part of that they were playing half
the games in Vegas just to make money
and
um
you know it was never going to leave the
family and so when we got a chance to do
this I think there's two things Adam
said hey Ryan if you're lucky to be a
part of the NBA like that's great if
you're if you win the lottery it's
almost like you can be the governor he's
like but no one gets their team I think
about that all the time brother I'm
always like petrified that I'm gonna
have to buy like
the Saints like you know like like I
think about like you know like am I
gonna pan like for me it's kind of like
Jets or bust like I'm not I think a lot
of my contemporaries friends you Matt
who just picked up the sons other people
I'm talking to I feel like there's a
macro like this would be cool I love the
sport I love the business I'm gonna be
able to achieve this goal for me I
always genuinely speak to myself about
like I wonder at 80 am I gonna hit the
panic button and just buy like the
Washington Nationals and baseball like
like I don't know like what's gonna
happen to your point the concept of
having that dream but then ending up
getting your team that's like needle and
a haystack because to your point timing
if the Johnsons decide to sell the Jets
next year it's going to be too early for
me like I could do a lot of things I'll
do what I can but like boy oh boy it
would be much better if that happened in
16 years
so so I've had to kind of look at it and
say hey look I I mean in and I was down
the road with another team and thank
goodness my wife's like Ryan remember
you're a jazz fan right like the dream
the dream can't be bigger than like the
mission and and like and this is after
the Jazz it basically said no like
timing's not right for us we're not
doing it and
and so I had to burn the bridge on the
other opportunity even though I thought
it might be one of the only ones there
and then six months later I get a call
going hey you still interested right and
it's like is this real now now back to
your question of like stepping into the
opportunity first of all I care about it
deeply I care about the community in a
way that
um there's probably days where it would
be nice not having all that
institutional knowledge in the 30 years
of growing up because there's things
there's things that I wouldn't see that
that require a lot more work
um and maybe I'm overcompensating for
given the history
um I see some other individuals where
whether it's a private Equity or group
or not they're not as emotional about it
I'm emotional like I want to win I want
I I know it's like to be a fan I see you
on Twitter like you get you get like
it's my biggest it's my biggest laugh I
have with myself when Jet fans are going
to yell at me and I'm gonna be like shut
your [__] mouth I'm a bigger fan than
you
I'm gonna bring up like weird like I'm
gonna bring up weird six round picks
from small schools that were punters and
be like I feel like my fights with fans
are gonna be like hey who was number 69
from Cincinnati offensive lineman from
you know in the 90s yo you don't know
Jason fabini then shut the [__] up yeah
Adrian Dantley was here the other night
and I was like dude I had a post I was
like geeking out I had a poster review
on my wall as a kid the palace Guard
from the saw Palace and everyone's like
what Brian why are you and I was like
whoa this is incredible right so
I think I think I understand that um but
also like we want to win and that makes
winning that much sweeter man and so I
think I think there's something special
I think the growth of Utah I think
coming in from that angle like with our
Tech movement that we've created Tech in
a lot of States has been theoretical
um we've experienced uh a Silicon Valley
Tech boom here in Utah which is
fundamentally changed our stuff and a
lot of people don't know it you know
when I analyze it from afar the
mountains a lot of people don't know it
because
Salt Lake or Utah has done incredibly
well in the B2B space on Tech
and so I think it's a hair under the
radar for the masses listening right now
because it's not consumer as much of
course there's been some great consumer
but to your point I'll let you rattle it
off like you and many of your
contemporaries that you grew up with in
the last 20 years 25 years you
established this incredible execution a
lot of it happened in B2B which is a why
it's a hair under the radar you agree
with that yeah yeah I mean we have we
have a lot of consumer companies but
look look in in actually very few places
outside of Silicon Valley have mastered
major B to C you know you look at
Facebook you look at Google I mean
Amazon's a little different
um but you know we're not watching
Nashville or Austin really pop out and
create b2c requires
um a lot of funding a lot of
um creativity
um and timing
um
you know when success breeds success so
entrepreneurs grow up watching what they
see around them and we've we've put on a
clinic when it comes to B2B software
enterprise software and in
infrastructure software and uh if if I
look around
um that being said I mean ancestry.com's
two doors down from me you know Vivint
where it was smart home and all of that
I mean we had three billion dollar
companies within a thousand yards in
Provo Utah where qualtrics started which
is which is insane I mean that was that
was a big a big moment but if you look
at what's happened because of the tech
growth and you know Adobe buying
omniture and Adobe moving here
um we've we're we're we're number one
for the the least unemployment right uh
upward Mobility is number one
um fastest growing States you know
seven out of the the last 10 years and
you look at compounding growth and what
that does it means that we're the
youngest state right now
right which you love like you love youth
I was a kid that had way too much
responsibility at such a young age in in
was was able to kind of grow into that
and I think that's what makes Utah
special especially right now is
um we've got a lot of Youth doing big
things and they have permission take me
behind the curtain you've been putting a
ton of energy for this All-Star Weekend
you've owned the Jazz for how long Ray
uh two years
in Sportsland
when the All-Star game comes to your
town that's a big deal right it's a
showcase you get to host the other
owners there's a lot going on there
right
uh
you know back to Youth and innovating
and back to the way I started this how
big are the stakes
in your mind that this is a home run
right because I've seen you really like
put a lot of energy to this is this back
to
you loved the All-Star Game and you
taught 30 years ago and it was this fun
thing and jam set and and you just are
doing it because you're that kind of
human and it's just kind of fun or back
for the all the entrepreneurs here who
by the way maybe hosting a conference at
their or might be even hosting a big
meeting at their office in a 40 office
infrastructure like what's hosting the
party like what does it mean is this
kind of like
you know just behind the curtain like
why is this important like what are you
thinking about why are you going so gun
hoe
so it is a showcase you get to do it
once every 30 years right and so I think
you give you back up to that premise
it's like we get one chance at this
um
coming out of the pandemic this is
probably the full first full sin to
All-Star game that both the League's
going behind and everything else
and that's been very apparent with
what's going on it's
really this is the League's event it is
the league show yeah Salt Lake is bigger
than just what the league is doing and
so that's what we're trying to do and
I'm going to get a little crazy here but
just to show you because you talk about
events that's what we've done at
qualtrics for 20 years I mean we hold we
host our big X4 Summit you've got your G
your your G friends like you're doing
all that like or g-con like you're doing
all of that like you know what like no
worries but but you know what you
actually just gave me a good idea I
might Rebrand V friends at the G friends
I'm gonna give that some thought but
keep going but it hey it works man but
but like if you look at my wall right
here like we've got like shower boards I
love it
we went and bought it Like Home Depot
because this is what we did at qualtrics
yeah and then if you look at it I'll
just show you I love it but you've got
like Wednesday Friday
and we've got every hour of everything's
going on and then Saturday and then
Sunday and we're saying all right if
you're coming through and we look at the
entire experience okay why what do we
have right here going on what other
parties are going on right we want
people to look at their their basically
their dance card that night and say hey
like
like we're activating things and so then
how does that manifest well in talking
to Trav in
the what what he's doing and we're like
hey let's bring Cactus Jack in and we we
need you to do something here here or
here he's like can we do this and that
and or when we're sitting together we're
saying hey let's let's let's do a q a or
let's do a talk at this time
and then we're just feeling that out to
say hey the overall experiences is is
completely curated and then we're asking
ourselves what could go wrong
just like you would there like what
could go wrong well there's not enough
Ubers well there's not enough Ubers for
event like this in any city right so
we're working with our mayor and our our
governor and taking our natural
Transportation that's always going and
augmenting it with you know 18 buses
that are now doing uh every 15 minute
Loop in the five hotels in the arena
and so this is all just part of asking
this and we're never going to get it all
right and everything's great till you
put the people until you put the people
in it
uh is is snow is is snow in play could
we get like a could we get like 23
inches because mother nature mother Nate
you know there's a great Russian saying
which is man makes plan and God laughs
Mother Nature has plans sometimes it it
is very very real and we've been getting
dumped on here in in nothing
is more enjoyable than watching Sundance
Film Festival come into town and then it
just dumps and and like no one's prep
for that everyone's all dressed up nice
they got all their outfits on and the
next thing you know it's just pounding
like two feet
um that's all in the cards but like can
I I want to ask you something before I
want to get ask you something before we
get out of here
talk to me about being a fan of players
of your favorite team then you're the
owner and you've got to make Personnel
decisions so not only were you a fan but
I know you well enough to know
that you walked in there day one and
you're looking to build relationships
you know Quail tricks was so based on
experience we just got to see
operational experience literally in real
time here and yet I also think you're
one of your greatest skills is Human
Experience I think you give a [__] about
that it matters you understand that is
the macro that to me is the ultimate
experience and so here you are you walk
in a year a year earlier you're going to
these games and you're a super fan of
the guys and team now you're the owner
now you become friends with them in the
first month or two I can't imagine like
you were kidding me candy store you're
dapping you're doing dinners this is
like you're pinching yourself and then
it gets even crazier because you bring
in one of the best Executives in sports
history and Danny Ainge who happens to
also be a Utah Legend I can't imagine
what's going through your mind on that
and then you guys are sitting down and
actually having conversations about
people like Rudy and Donovan and like
making big boy decisions
how tough was that to translate from fan
to friend to now you have to detach from
both feelings be in a conference room
and and like make decisions that are in
the best interest of the franchise it's
brutal man like I think that uh like I
mean tomorrow's the trade deadline and
here we are like it's it's super it's
super difficult uh because you care
deeply about people I'm a people person
life's about people
and
um
I I think you've got to take a step back
and say hey like
we're all in the NBA and the good news
is there's a lot of people who want to
be in Utah and they want to stay in Utah
and um
and and that being said like
you you've also were trying to build a
championship and and you you're gonna
have to make tough decisions but I also
think that that's business like you have
to be able to manage polar opposite
emotions
like you've got to be able to grow and
also make money and be profitable you've
got to be able to
um care so deeply about people and in
Tech and then have them walk out the
door for their next gig we talk about
that all the time Gary like like you're
you're you're training so many of these
CMOS that are now going to go out and
lead the world and then you finally get
someone that you're jiving with and it's
like hey someone calls up and says
here's the top position that is managing
emotions and so I think this goes very
similarly and I think your Effectiveness
as a leader or an entrepreneur a
business person is a spouse a
relationship is how you can manage these
polar opposite things and and Danny
Danny is incredible he's one of one and
what I love about Danny is he basically
does not lie
it's huge it's so it's so funny you said
that you were I apologize for
interrupting yeah it's so weird you said
that literally as you were talking I've
been going through a pretty solid
transformation of being more candorous
you know I'd like to think because I'm a
human I'm protecting my own feelings
that it wasn't about lying it was about
skirting at worst it was about passive
aggressiveness but like I hated conflict
and I literally it was funny as you were
talking I can't believe you just said
that about Danny because that's what
that's the only thing that will work in
player relationships I was literally
dreaming of me having a quarterback me
deciding you know talking to him and
being like you're my [__] guy we're
gonna go down burning together and then
like nine months later it's just clear
to me as the owner of like this kid is
not that guy
and then like trading him on the day
before draft day for a third round pick
and that kid being like [__] you Gary
Right versus me saying look I just need
to be upfront with you you're my guy
for life but if the data on the field
shows something that makes my intuition
change on it or what your activities are
off the field I'll I'll tell you that
things are changing that's a very
different framework and so to your point
Danny's ability to not lie is like
respected by other GMS respected by
agents but most of all respected by
players and I think it really matters
yeah he told me he's told me that from
the beginning right when he came in he
said I've been in the league 46 years
I've been a GM I've been a president
and now I'm the CEO
I've never asked for a job once it's all
been handed to me I know how I wanted to
be treated as a player red arbuck sat me
down and said hey I've got to trade you
where do you want to go
and I appreciated that I got traded
three times he's like I had five kids
like it was hard but like it's part of
the game at the end of the day I get
paid millions of dollars to play in the
NBA and that's like such a bad thing and
that's and that's hard for right that's
hard for dynamic people loving people
like you and me I know you well enough
now knowing to walk into that like it's
just like
you know when I when I walked into your
office the other day similar to what
happens here just like it's fam you're
like that kid was a freshman at BYU when
he like it was an intern like I get it
it's like exactly how I say it and
honestly it is a vulnerability
you know I mean like my it's my Natural
Instincts if I buy the Jazz when you did
to tell Rudy and Donovan like you're
gonna be here forever I'm gonna retire
your number we're gonna [__] win two
times like it's just it's the hype it's
the excitement and you mean it at the
time during my first week
because it was a shortened coveted
season I I hadn't even closed on the
team but we had signed the deal and the
Millers said hey basically like okay
your first two assignments there you go
you got to go re-sign Don and Rudy
like right off like I mean I was like
one day into it and those like I was
like okay here we go and then like
there's an organization and everything
and those were not I mean and then
looking back if I would have been like
hey two years later this is where we
would be I would have said you're crazy
but
um
like it's
it's just part of the journey and it's
part of leadership and you want to be
around people that are going to push you
the easy thing to do was was was
probably just to let things go the same
way and hope for a different outcome but
for whatever reason we had to look ahead
and say hey this probably isn't in the
cards and like I'll give you a great
example like
you know I think there was a lot of
narrative out there that hey we weren't
going to make any moves till after all
star because we had two All-Stars that
would be in Utah
and we make a big move this summer even
with the fact that it was like not in
the cards that we'd have in All-Star we
get Lowry marketing and he unanimously
becomes an All-Star and it's just a
great story
of like
how
like change sometimes
um
can can be scary and get in the way
especially in a public environment but
at the same time like you need to band
together with the team you've got for
that moment and and these are all
chapters and you need to look at every
chapter and say hey that was one hell of
a chapter and you know that's my pitch
for everyone in Utah like this should be
the happiest time that that you've had
in the NBA and I think that you know if
I look at our players right now um I
think if you went one by one with who's
here they're gonna say hey I've never
been this happy you know to that point
to make this relevant for every
individual person change
is scary but often can be good my big
thing to most people I talk to all the
DMs I get from the kids and the parents
and just the way I live my life is if
you are struggling right now if it
doesn't feel good
and when I say struggling I mean
inconvenience sometimes even right like
you know I think people think that you
have to be like burning to the ground
right and they're like they don't even
realize they're just genuinely unhappy
day to day I mean do you wake up on
Monday morning
and are you in a this is awesome like
this is good like solid not like it's
okay or like I can deal with it or I
have to like whether it's a relationship
or a professional thing or like living
by what your parents want or what
Society wants
you know
I think it was really powerful what you
just said change a lot of times people
think you have to hit rock bottom that
always happens people will change when
they hit quote unquote Rock Bottom I
think people have to change when it's
kind of not good or consistently not
good or like below decent or like a pain
in the ass and
my point to them always is well you know
it's not working right now so this kind
like this concept of deciding well it
could be worse you know is a little bit
tricky when you're already not in a
great spot if you're and back so like
you were talking in sports terms of like
do we feel like we have the makeup to
win an NBA championship which is the
goal of the thing that we do here
for me that translates it's a good way
to sum this all up for Value to every
person regardless of their interest in
sports or the All-Star Game in Utah by
the way one more time while I'm on this
rant I'm coming to Utah if you're in the
general area I'm about to put out a lot
of content a blog post with the details
of my thing Ryan and the NBA have been
so gracious and even gave a discount
code to the jam thing that I'm gonna put
in my podcast so please come see me in
Utah I'm going to be around quite a bit
and I have a couple official things one
my one-on-one chat with Ryan we're gonna
be talking q a in business and then my
own little q a booth and then I'll just
be out and about on Town what I love
about the downtown is it's you know you
can find me at some level
um but yeah I mean I think you have to
change if you're not happy and that
comes in fancy amazing situations like
you running a team trying to win an NBA
championship but it also means something
for Carl who's driving to work right now
listening to this podcast and just hates
his [__] job and it's kind of like
you know you hate your job so why not
make a change and try something else if
that second thing is worse then do it
again and just get out of that Rhythm to
your point yeah there's ruts that you
fall in and anything and they're just
they're just ruts um it in Tech
I think is public companies everyone's
watching a lot of activists come in and
activists will come into the company and
everyone's afraid because they're going
to make the changes and and it's almost
like we all need to be the activists of
our own lives
right like what would an activist do in
your life someone came in like what
would they change okay now you go do
that I always hear this story once that
and I don't know how true it is but it
was that you know Coca-Cola got into a
meeting had all the executives put their
phone in a basket and said hey we're
about ready to lose the McDonald's
contract and it's going to Pepsi and we
have to pitch in 12 hours
what are we going to do and everyone in
the room came up with all these things
that they were going to do to change the
relationship and better of it and then
the executive said actually we're not
going to lose it but go do all that
stuff anyways I [__] love that all
right what would an active is or what
would you do if you were to do this we
would all get up and actually we're in a
comfortably resilient we just showed it
through covet how resilient we are 100
brother I love you can't wait to see you
everybody get your ass to Utah thanks
Ryan all right we'll see you bro